America is shaped primarily by two I
think number one is its isolation we are
protected behind behind behind our
oceans and that is as true today as it's
been before we went through World War 1
in World War two without any significant
damage at all to our homeland almost no
other major country in the world
certainly none of the major countries in
Eurasia did that and it really does
shape the way we feel about the world
the second thing is that we have but is
largely because we are settled by
immigrants and a mixture of the world
it's a we had a largely kind of blank
page on which to write and we are
largely our own creation for good and
bad in a way that is simply not true of
other most other countries I think of
the Russians a great deal there is a
country there is a group of people who
have been invaded again and again and
again and it's a totally different
culture as a result of that than his ire
culture we've never been invaded
essentially except briefly by the
British in two wars around the time of
the revolution so I think the isolation
and the ability to develop ourselves as
we saw fit are the two really important
you